l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo su un
qualche cosa che mi ha colpito
ultimamente che è 23 modi di sfruttare
al massimo i tuoi vent'anni un articolo
che ho trovato in giro allora a parte il
fatto che la pagina si chiama 26 modi di
sfruttare al massimo ma che cazzo
siccome io ho vent'anni
vorrei leggere questa cosa a commentarla
in diretta sarà alquanto strano perché
sono cose alquanto strane prova beh
alcune ragazzine salterò perché non sono
divertenti ma altre tenetevi forte
numero uno impara e non serve per forza
andare all'università fa esperienza sul
lavoro viaggia leggi qualcosa che ti
cambi gioca in un ambiente sempre ben
illuminato fi pause regolari ogni circa
15 minuti di gioco smettere
immediatamente di giocare non giocare se
non hai almeno 18 anni ormai ono 20
pezzi esci con un sacco di ragazze di
ragazzi sono ragazzi carini interessanti
divertenti e ti piace di più quando stai
insieme a loro no imparerai molto date
molto più ma [ __ ] liberati dei
colli asterisco asterisco asterisco nin
che non ti piacciono
amava
ma
da registrare che assaggia cv nuovi e
bello e fa bene mi pare l'avesse detto
aristotele ciao farvi vuoi provare il
mio nuovo più che il cola merda grazie
guarda continuamente prova poi comprare
stivare i costosissimi in qualunque
momento della tua vita ma il momento
dopo il quale non potrai più andare ai
concerti negli scantinati arriva
abbastanza presto
spiegami qual è il problema di andare a
vedere i concerti negli scantinati dio
spiega
[Musica]
a
[Applauso]
sono 300 euro dedica molto tempo alle
tue amiche affittate viene a casa al
mare fatemi una vacanza perché una volta
che rivelano i bambini sarete
impegnatissime e i bambini arriveranno
prima di quanto pensiate vai a maria i
bambini i bambini arriveranno prima che
ce lo aspettiamo mai anni ma che cazzo
sedia i tuoi nonni di raccontarti
com'era la vita quando loro avevano
vent'anni
ai miei tempi non c'erano tutte queste
tecnologie di merda era tutto una spesa
organizza una festa che spacca davvero
capraia li extrafesta n'è venuto quasi
incazzo d nessuno solo nel 20 pochi ma
buoni vero frate molla il lavoro se lo
detesti le persone che cambiano lavoro
sono sempre quelle più felici beh in
realtà io ho la fortuna grazie a dio di
fare un lavoro che mi piace un sacco che
quello dello youtuber quindi in questo
caso no se poi un giorno non mi
divertirò più a fare queste cagate tipo
guardare estetici e magari smetterò
indosso a quello che vuoi se ti
piacciono le tuniche metti telesur di
lettori che non metta tra insomma sei tu
che decidi
nei guai per la 6a noi avevamo perso col
parma da solo che bello essere donna
spendi pure un botto per andare ai
concerti perché non ti pentirai mai di
aver visto rosario muniz in carne ed
ossa mai asi ticketone se rosario
beyoncé muniz conosciuta come beyoncé è
una campagna realizza il prima possibile
che ogni donna e se difetti e che il tuo
corpo e magnifico così come non fingere
l'orgasmo prima spiegherai al tuo
partner che non sei venuta trova al tipo
di allenamento che fa per te fare
esercizio sembra una forma crudele di
tortura psicologica ma a me non ne sarei
felice
[Musica]
masturbati storia dalla fretta si cerca
di capire che cosa riesce a rilassarti
[Musica]
fai qualcosa di folle buttati se non ora
quando
[Musica]
come ti ho presieduto birichino stronzo
quindi ragazzi queste erano le cose le
tante cose che si possono fare a
vent'anni a 21 no solo 20 perché sennò è
reato pero che video vi sia piaciuto non
aveva senso questa cosa però dovevo
assolutamente farla perché non lo so
neanche io perché quindi ragazzi spero
che video vi sia piaciuto e cosa sento
seguito è piaciuta da questo momento mi
piace anche la faccia di facebook e con
un livido trovate la descrizione
lasciate un mi piace se anche voi
vorreste avere vent'anni per fare queste
cose epiche molto epica se non servirsi
di scrittori ci vediamo al prossimo
vinto e ragazzi ho appena scassato una
lampada